foreign
2020.
our world shrank
from nearly 200 countries
to one
suddenly we were all trapped
unable to move Beyond quarantines and
Border closures
do you remember how painful that was
being separated from our families and
loved ones for what felt like eternity
missing birthdays missing graduations
missing weddings
missing funerals
canceling trips
counseling reunions
in life's biggest moments
we were trapped
that might have been a temporary coveted
reality back then but I had already been
familiar with it my entire life and I
still am
not because of pandemic isolation but
because of passports isolation
if you haven't heard of it welcome to
the world of second class passports
when my friends of American French or
Australian passports want to travel this
is what the world looks like
they can wake up choose from more than
80 percent of the world's countries book
a flight and head there Visa free
this is what it looks like for me with
my Lebanese passport where I can only
access 20 of the world's country's
visa-free
so what does this mean what do I do when
I need to go somewhere where I can't
just show up
let me walk you through the maze
first and foremost I must start thinking
about it ages in advance
I prepare all my documents to verify my
legitimacy a five-page visa application
an employment verification a letter of
no objection to travel from my employer
proof of residency bank statements
insurance coverage recent photographs
books flight booked accommodation a
detailed itinerary and sometimes a proof
that I was indeed born also known as a
birth certificate
foreign
I look for a Visa appointments often
they are fully booked when I'm lucky and
I find one
I take a day off work
I go eat in line
I pay hundreds of dollars in Visa fees
I go through an interview
and I Surrender my passport that's kept
there for two weeks or 12 weeks no one
knows
and just like that
I'm trapped
all this and the Visa is never
guaranteed sometimes rejected with no
explanation if it's approved it's only
temporary until I need to go through
this fund maze all over again
and if like me you work in a job with
constant travel good luck explaining to
your manager with a first class passport
why you cannot travel because your
passport is tracked to process the Visa
that you need to travel
the last time
the mental burden
and the financial strain this creates is
agonizing
I missed out on school trips on business
trips on seeing my partner for a whole
year
I missed out on my best friend's civil
wedding in France because I had no time
to do the Visa and then again on her
traditional wedding in Morocco because I
was denied the Visa
I was once the night boarding to a
flight heading to my own country because
I mistakenly booked a stopover somewhere
where I'm not allowed to Transit
and this
doesn't affect me alone
seven out of every 10 people on earth
that is 5.5 billion
need visas to access the majority of the
world's countries
without a surprise most have Asian
or African passports
this
sucks
what do people do
well few in this group who have the
means resort to taking matters in their
own hands by buying themselves a dual
premium passport
in fact there's a whole booming and
legal markets out there to acquire
better passports the most popular
Channel offered by more than 20
governments is called citizenship by
investment where people in needs can pay
hundred thousand dollars to three
million dollars to get the coveted
document in their hands
not because they have any desire to
emigrate
but because they want to buy
their own human
rights
why would they pay this much you ask
because this is not just about travel
but also about accessing Financial
educational and Healthcare opportunities
where needed
it's about having an insurance policy
that guarantees your personal security
it's about having
what I call
the freedom pass
I learned about the reality of this
Freedom pass when I was 12.
in the summer of 2006 a war broke out in
my home country
the single airport was bombed
highways were not safe
we were trapped
I'm gonna die here I thought
until I heard of an exit way
mom my school friend said they are
escaping with their parents and the ship
stand for evacuation can we leave as
well
no honey we can't live
the ships are not for us
we don't have another passport like your
friends
then and there I understood there were
two classes of people
those who hold the freedom pass
and those who don't
now how do we fix this
where do we start
can we even fix this
yes
the status quo and arbitrary
classification of humanity is not a
given fact of life
our modern passport system was actually
invented in 1920 just hundred years ago
to expedite cues at European train
stations after World War One
before then travel had been more or less
unrestricted
many scholars have started to question
and to rethink the system
some economists even argue we should
just open all borders
I understand that's a bit extreme
and I'm not here to argue for that
such black or white narratives create
fear inaction and more closure
while I once was an idealist
life turned me a pragmatist so let's
start there
as a first step Visa processes can be
made faster cheaper and more digitized
while still preserving security
this may seem so daunting but it really
is not
in the past years some governments such
as those of Thailand New Zealand and the
UAE have taken steps to improve the
status quo by offering visitor visas on
arrival or by making their applications
quick and fully digital
at the same time some startups are
working on innovating within the current
and efficient system
such actions not only benefit visitors
like myself but the country's economies
as well
in fact the UN World tourism
organization has shown that facilitating
visitor visas can increase tourism by up
to 25 percent create billions of dollars
of GDP and millions of new jobs
while much more remains to be done
such progress steps are encouraging
because small steps can lead to powerful
change
and for change to happen faster
it needs action
collaboration
and above all it needs awareness
I believe that the status quo can and
should be changed and I hope you do too
until then
I
and 5.5 billion others will still abide
by the rules of the Visa maze because we
won't let arbitrary systems Rob us from
enjoying lives most precious moments
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]